>>> A IGHT AND MYSTERIOUS
FIREBALL FLYING THROUGH THE SKY
ACROSS SCOTLAND AND PARTS OF
IRELAND AND THE UK WEDNESDAY
NIGHT.
>> HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE SAW THIS
THING.
IT WAS IN THE SKY, LOOK.
THERE YOU GO.
FOR ABOUT 10 TO 20 SECONDS.
CNN'S SPACE AND DEFENSE
CORRESPONDENT KRISTEN FISHER IS
WITH US NOW.
WHAT WAS IT?
>> WELL, WE DON'T KNOW YET WITH
100% CERTAINTY, BUT A GROUP
CALLED THE UK METEOR NETWORK IS
CONVINCED IT WAS A METEOR, WHICH
IS A SMALL PIECE OF AN ASTEROID
WHICH WAS BREAKING UP AS IT
ENTERED THE EARTH'S ATMOSPHERE.
THE OTHER POSSIBLE THEORY THAT'S
BEEN FLOATING AROUND IS IT WAS A
PIECE OF SPACE JUNK.
LIKE AN OLD SATELLITE OR A SPENT
ROCKET BODY BURNING UP AS IT
RE-ENTERED THE EARTH'S
ATMOSPHERE.
BUT MOST EXPERTS SEEM TO BE
COMING INTO AGREEMENT THAT THIS
WAS A METEOR.
BUT WHATEVER IT WAS, IT WAS A
SPECTACLE ACROSS SCOTLAND,
NORTHERN IRELAND, AND NORTHERN
ENGLAND.
MORE THAN 800 PEOPLE REPORTED IT
TO THE UK METEOR NETWORK, AND IT
WAS CAPTURED AS YOU CAN SEE HERE
IN TONS OF CELL PHONE VIDEOS,
RING DOORBELL CAMERAS CAUGHT IT,
AND THE REASON WE HAVE SUCH
INCREDIBLE FOOTAGE OF IT IS
BECAUSE MOST FIREBALLS, THEY
ONLY LAST IN THE SKY FOR A FEW
SECONDS.
THIS ONE COULD BE SEEN FOR A
FULL 20 SECONDS.
WHICH IS VERY RARE.
IT WAS ALSO PRETTY SLOW MOVING,
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE ALSO
REPORTED THAT IT WAS ACTUALLY
CHANGING COLOR.
SO THERE WAS SOME REALLY UNUSUAL
CHARACTERISTICS ABOUT THIS
THING, BUT AS ALL THE DATA COMES
IN, IT'S LOOKING MORE AND MORE
LIKE IT WAS A METEOR, BUT SPACE
JUNK NOT OFFICIALLY RULED OUT
YET.
>> OKAY.
I'M NO ROCKET SCIENTIST, BUT